[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about humor
talking about activism talking about
breaking news writing performing
shit-stirring arts culture nightlife all
this cool stuff we have Stewart
shuffelin joining us aka
broke ass Stewart hello how you doing
thanks for coming on for having me who
week what am I looking at we you're
gonna be looking at me yeah and well I'm
just you know doing the intro and outro
and stuff everything all they're looking
at camera Stewart your work has been
crazy cool the last 15 years you've been
doing this in the area since 2004 yeah
so you've seen so much of what's
happening yeah
because the bay area has turned in many
ways into an nuts technological place
from more of arts hippie play sure sure
yeah and there's well you know we'll
we'll be unpacking this and so much more
in the conversation again it's been 15
years all Stewart's links are below to
go and check out his work and it's
mostly been doing things like writing
about activism humor breaking news are
kind of like the main themes mhm and
then you know we'll we'll jump into that
as we go you know where did I want to
know where did broke-ass Stewart come
from that's like this whole like being
young broken beautiful knowing how to
like get around like with a little bit
of money mm-hmm right sure lots of
different things so it started it's
funny years ago I was working in a candy
store in North Beach place called eat
Chocolat oh and it's still there
and somebody for my neighborhood growing
up in San Diego came in and they
this woman who's now his wife and as
they're leaving she gave me her card and
said she's a travel writer and I said I
want to be a travel writer so I just
decided to become one and I started I
made my zine for those who don't know
what a Zima is before there was blogs
there was Eames you could go to Kinkos
or some photocopy store and literally
physically cut and paste and Xerox and
boom staple you have your own
publication so I started off doing
broke-ass to where it's God living
cheaply in San Francisco because I was
broke and everyone who was broken we
needed to find cheap things to do so I
just made it my little travel zine and
that eventually I got to do writing for
Lonely Planet out of that and then after
that I was looking for a second well you
know it was cool but I'd read all the
distribution by myself with like my bus
pass and and my and my backpack you know
and my sneakers and so I was like what
school to do this thing but I want to do
it on a bigger level so I found a book
deal of all places on Craigslist and I
always say that I was looking for a blow
job I got a book deal instead which is
kind of true we're not really kind of so
yeah
so I did throw the numbers that became
two books it was broke after which guy
living cheaply in San Francisco then I
moved to New York and did a New York
book and then I did a New York version
of the guide to living cheaply mm-hmm
that's great yeah and then it was it was
like we share like urban outfitters and
some like that and then eventually I am
I probably how about later but then I
eventually did a TV show in 2011 you on
IFC which is a travel show called young
broken beautiful and then yeah a bunch
of other adventures but that's kind of
how it all started okay interesting so
back back then you could you could
yourself go and and get your own
publication published quite easily at
like a Kinkos it's hard work well you
didn't get about as you publish it
yourself you just did it you know yeah
self-published and then you would bring
these copies with you in your back pack
and distribute them yeah local business
I was in like 30 stores in the city 30
source yeah that's great and how did you
hey you know how did you find the the
guide you know to living cheaply how
would you find the different locations
around the Bay Area that you thought
were the right one yeah to write about
you know I would just kind of you know
friends or friends and friends are
talking
with the rep - and stuff they found you
know some internet research as well you
know I you know especially when I did it
for New York I did it much Masada Klee
and I would like you know pick a
neighborhood do a bunch of pre research
and then go out find those places I did
research on and then like stumble into
other cool stuff - along the way
okay so who's like a lot of
word-of-mouth you and then as you would
go it would kind of like open doors as
you would keep going and exploring was
word of mouth it was like ladies are
doing research online I never like back
when a well city search was existing and
so I did some research on with that when
I was like doing my first zine you know
that kind of thing
that word zine yeah crazy okay so then
the book came from that then the book in
New York came from that too which is
very interesting because it would you
would you say that the San Francisco and
New York ones had there was like overlap
in the Venn diagram right of like kind
of like similar cool things to do for
cheap yeah I mean I mean obviously
different locales you know but I mean
the ethos was the same ethos like you're
young broke and beautiful you know doing
the best you can with what you have him
having a good life you know that motto
go that's cool how did you come up with
the motto just popped my head one day
when I woke up yeah maybe I've been
doing some writing and reading some
poetry edition like he came kind of came
something just appeared one day you know
those stickers are all over the world in
fact to get to stick with you good we'd
love one now yeah you're young you're
young broke and beautiful mm-hmm I love
the stickers are all over the world now
like I somebody just tag me in one
there's one in a Munich I think a whoa
there's New Orleans of Thailand Israel
everywhere yeah the the motto itself is
it's it gives you that little bit of
first of all you're beautiful is very
important then also you know the fact
that most people think that they're
potentially you know broken that means
that there's something that they've done
maybe wrong with their life this is kind
of reassuring to say that you know so
many of us are young and broke and
beautiful and like go and find this is
kind of like is inspiring people to find
maybe their self actualization sure you
know it's like use it to hey you know as
a motivation help you grind and hustle
you know and like you know there's
nothing wrong with being broke there's
nothing wrong being poor don't let them
tell you any differently
what's wrong is the things that keep us
broken keep us poor they're out of our
control you know like the system of
people like Jeff Bezos who don't pay
[ __ ] taxes you know or Amazon and
Netflix not having to pay taxes because
they get paid our tax cuts you know so
it's it's not you that's keeping you
poor sure you can work hard we all
should work hard to do the best we can
but also it's systems are keeping us
down so I mean there's difference
between be important broke to you know
poor is is part of the socio-economic
system that you know he's off sometimes
inherited you know broke is temporary
it's not forever it's not a class hmm
you know so and there's differences yeah
that's that's an important
distinguishment right there because when
you broke is temporary broke is a period
of time when you there's gotta be some
sort of like a force as well that comes
from within you to want to not be broke
you know that's something that I think
ourselves and so many others have went
through and then also it helps so much
to have like a mentor or someone else
that can help you maybe with with
getting those you know that that job
that you actually align with and like
helping you you know get not broke and
broke so relative to you know it's like
you know in San Francisco people make a
hundred thousand dollars a year a broke
you know especially when their rents
like four grand right it's crazy I mean
I definitely gotta dollars a year
here that but I mean you know really the
grand scheme of things even people who
think they're rich aren't really
actually rich you know the people don't
realize how rich people are how rich
rich people really are if you make a
million dollars a year you're making
over eighty seven thousand dollars a
month thirty three thousand dollars a
month
grab this your make I've never made
eighty two thousand dollars in a year
yeah
eighty and these are the people who get
tax breaks make eighty three thousand
dollars a month that's rich
you know yeah that's a nuts yeah that
breakdown makes things yeah because you
love doing but they could be using
numbers like millions bands like we know
what they are when you break it down per
month you realize how yeah it's crazy
yeah
it just seems as though no human can
actually spend that money and then be
happy anyway there's like what as you
climb up this hierarchy of power
influence and wealth it just seems as
though the happiness levels even
decrease because you have to deal with
materialistic possessions you have to
deal with like thousands of people that
you potentially employ you have to deal
with you have to deal with you can't
tell if somebody's trying to like come
at you or your family and some sort of a
way that is trying to maybe harm you or
harass sure like so many complicated
things come from this yet we like s
culture prop it up as such a
distinguished burger it's funny we have
this weird thing like everything about
our culture from the day you're born it
says buy buy buy consume consume consume
write they do everything you can to
attain this [ __ ] but then if you go into
debt to do that or you don't or you are
not rich yeah you go into debt to do
this then society laughs at you for
being poor for working hard and and and
it discredits you and you you like can
get into trouble for working so hard to
do the things you're told to do by
everything around you it's getting crazy
have you you've been seeing a lot of
this in the 15 years yeah I've been in
the bay and did you see it give us give
us a picture on in terms of the Ludo I
think a lot of the buildings that were
initially that are now here on like the
Rincon Hill area all of those massively
large new condos were not here no yeah
so tell us about because that's like
that's like a massive jump in yeah
inequality tell us about kind of where
you saw that from oh four until nineteen
now I mean really things took off in
2011 started with the Twitter tax break
you know all these companies like you
know Twitter and uber and all these
things and in market were threatening to
leave the city and you know the economy
just was had voluntary cently and I mean
I think I see how it made sense kind of
at the moments but they just haven't
held these companies accountable and
they're getting these big payroll taxes
and tax breaks rather and so they're
just helping the rich get richer and it
really what happened was they gave all
these tax breaks to companies who said
they're gonna build great jobs here in
San Francisco and they created a lot of
jobs in San Francisco but those didn't
go to the people who lost their jobs in
the recession they imported people for
those jobs so even so sure maybe
unemployment went down because that
person who was unemployed got evicted
you know or had to sur lost their place
and had to move short people like filled
those jobs but they weren't san
Franciscans and we have this huge wealth
inequality gap in in meaning in America
but really in sandwiches goes out of
control you have people that are making
so much freaking money and not being
part of the community at all like
someone like Jack Dorsey you know like
he's made his wealth off the backs of
and horrors and sadness of San
Franciscans losing their homes you know
and abstractly by like you know hey
where do you where your workers gonna
live where somebody else lived before
you know or in the new house and the new
housing but yeah but even that mean
that's come with your TV I mean we need
everyone we need more housing totally
better we need to do it ethically and
smart and like like affordably you
there's ways you can build housing that
that are for not just the top not only
that there's a hundred thousand and the
unit's the Bay Area and so we need to
put like a vacancy tax to force these
greedy landlords to stop being [ __ ]
greedy pricks and think about more than
just themselves in their wallets why are
they keeping the unit's vacant I mean
there's a lot of reasons some of them
are like doing an air B&B or whatever
they're doing the interview some of them
are that some of them are just like
waiting to the price go up you know sure
sure you know you you you speak about
this in 2011 you give us this picture of
like you know what does this is the
tough thing what does a city do we just
saw this with you know Long Island City
right with Amazon what does a city do
this is a very interesting economic and
an social and political and just growth
quandary that society faces at times you
have a Twitter and uber that's your on
Market Street
they say that hey like we need tax break
incentives in order for us to keep our
our rapidly growing company here and
bringing all this talent here and
building up your local businesses and
etc here and so the city usually says ok
and then you what kind of economic
growth you see versus if you run the
simulation let's say and they leave you
know what would happen and I yeah but
then what would happen in terms of the
you know the you know what what do you
think we didn't have a problem here
there was no economic just big problems
in San Francisco we already said yes
strong towards a industry with a huge
advertising age industry here we have a
huge culinary industry you know we
didn't need detective Jim come around
the technically she was already here
there's already some stuff here holy
[ __ ] you go to Cleveland take your money
yeah and go to go to Detroit that needs
right more than you know you know and so
like I was in Columbus Ohio recently and
Columbus was on the short list of
classes possibly possible places where
Amazon was going to go and then I was
talking the tours and people there
they're really excited I was like you
shouldn't be excited you should be
worried because I've seen this happen
I've seen it happen in Seattle I've seen
it happen in San Francisco you see it up
into New York these companies come in
and they do not good neighbors they
don't care about you know the people who
are here they don't that they don't look
at it this is a place to be partisan
they'll get in a place just to make
money you know and but they do Long
Island City was incredible because the
it's it's like when they promise like a
stadium or a Super Bowl or the Olympics
is gonna be good for a city he's gonna
bring all this revenue it but it never
does right
it never does how much does the family
the average family that's trying to you
know feed their kids and get up from a
massive yeah right I mean that coming
for the city even like you know that the
like wouldn't we see from Twitter and
uber and all these other major tech
giants coming into the city right we see
maybe we saw some things happen that are
a little bit more difficult for us to
perceive may be things like the amount
of housing
it's increased maybe like maybe crime
potentially decreased maybe amount of
foot traffic at local businesses
increased so I've got pushback on all
three of those points crime hasn't they
just pushed it from my neighborhood in
the Tenderloin so the Tenderloin you
know
so mr. soma it's done nothing to leave
you at homelessness it's created more
homelessness and created less housing
while there's more housing being built
there's also more people to fill that
housing and also a lot of the housing
being built isn't even going to local
people it's speaking about by investment
people and it's just sitting there empty
from around the world right and you can
even I wanted to do an experiment and
you can push back on those other points
quick it's just that like I want to do
an experiment where I took a camera on
Treasure Island and I looked at the San
Francisco skyline on a time-lapse mm-hmm
and I wanted to see out of all those
condo windows I wanted to see how many
of them at night actually light up
because if the percentage is like - only
20% of the windows night after night
after night are lighting up and that
maybe only 20 percent of the actual days
of the year sure they're actually in use
sure what are we doing building all
these all these extra condos for people
from around the world to buy us a fourth
sixth house I know and a lot of Chinese
investors were calling them safety
deposit boxes in the sky interesting
because there's this an investment that
you know that you know they'd put some
money in and it would go up you know
yeah yeah I mean sure there are things
that have been beneficial that it's got
but there has been a lot more tax
revenue for the city of San Francisco
a lot more money you know but I mean
yeah but you know how that works but
yeah yeah I mean when you said nobody
makes money off these things that are
happening to the city somebody does yeah
most of the people that are already
making money just not the middle and
horn class yeah well you know the
question you know when people say oh
it's progress it's all progress but the
question is that's a new benefit from
the progress do you the middle and poor
ever benefit from a Twitter uber Amazon
locating into a metropolis I mean you
know when people were like oh you know
traffic you know brings local businesses
you know what they did they built their
own goddamn cab for two years you
then they eat there every day yeah yeah
and so my question it always becomes
this but then that you put then there's
also the dry cleaning or like the shoe
sports gear or whatever like retail or
serve service industry right there's
tons of other yeah this is that I mean
they're absolutely there are things that
happen but I mean you know we've just
seen services built for these people so
if you take an uber to work every day
right and then all you didn't you you
eat all your meals at work you wear the
t-shirt of your work right you take uber
home
are you ever in San Francisco really
yeah it doesn't really seem like like it
yeah you might you might go out spend
some money on Saturday night yeah and
maybe you might go to Lake Tahoe or one
of the other cities and spend some in
California right yeah but even like even
the nightlife stuff I've seen a lot of a
lot of bars and clubs and restaurants
are getting hit because well the
restaurants are whole other thing the
bars and clubs because people don't go
out like they used to cuz your people
they're working 80 hours a week and
don't have time to spend the money plus
they're spending $4,000 a month on rent
yeah you know so I don't think this is
these things are good they're not good
for places exam just go places like San
Francisco New York Seattle allayed where
there's already robust industries that
are are doing well we don't need it
interesting so you you could even
potentially make a case for recommending
the massive metropolis to turn away the
tech tax breaks and ask even then ask
the country to say why don't you move to
st. Louis or Birmingham Detroit the
truffle oh I mean there's lots of places
that you save industry that don't
anymore that need the meat industry and
we'll give you all the tax breaks maybe
aprons that we have all that venture
capital firms here call them vampire
capital firms and like those are the
[ __ ] who are also really doing
this - it's a lot of it's you know it's
really wealthy people that are already
rich that are like using playing with
with dominoes yeah hoping they could get
some more money yeah yeah no yeah I was
definitely very closely reading about
how the amount of venture money just you
know if you look at it from like the
early you know 1990s when it was just
starting was like the biggest funds were
like you know 20 million dollar funds
now it's like
100 million-dollar funds like that is a
massive jump in terms of venture funding
and and again it's it's like we're the
unicorns
I want the 1 billion dollar unicorns I
want to you know it's like it's turned
into you know do you like our week
where's our humanity there's no humanity
there that's the problem I mean
especially that you know it used to they
presumably the stock market was created
so that the average working person could
you know buy could get a little bit
taste of that money from the company
they worked they could buy stocks from
their company or that you know they
could they can make but you know once
the stock market and she like that
stopped being for regular people when it
all became beholden to shareholders
you know they became like these
companies stuff caring about their
working people who bought stocks in
there and cared more about the people
who bought 20,000 stocks stocks in that
stuff
you know and like and so it's same kind
of thing where it's like it doesn't help
the working people at all it's just rich
people getting rich and then when you're
like I haven't I'm beholden to my
shareholders to do this I'm sorry for
polluting your River the shareholders
grow you know that's the worst the I
think one of the worst aspects of
capital markets right now that we're
rewriting is that shareholder extraction
very methods it's a go it's a massive
perverse incentive system it's not
sharing ownership with workers that well
it's not sharing ownership with
communities that well literally the
people that are buying the services that
the workers are making that are that
they should all get pieces of the puzzle
that are building this valuation of this
organization and then these embedded
growth obligations as well egos as Eric
Weinstein pointed out just like it's
it's it's disgusting like you have to
grow you have to grow you have to go
from a hundred to a thousand employees
from a million to 10 million in revenue
you have to that's the only way like no
there's other ways you don't have to do
that it's it's obscene it's obscene it's
not good for anybody except for like the
people of job you know people who are
gonna be rich are already rich and
they're just gonna get richer you know
[ __ ] them well do you live in the city
yes
yeah well you're doing alright oh yeah
wearing controlling I'm lucky yeah
[ __ ] lucky man and we're and we're
lucky to we're barely keeping afloat
ourselves and meanwhile you know where
are these you know benefits for artists
entrepreneurs for people that have lived
here for decades where are the benefits
that that that help them stay afloat
themselves and help them get by and help
them creatively flourish it's I don't
know yeah it's not coming to me I've
done of you we're not so so then so then
that something again this this comes to
like this how do we how do we rewrite
some of the ways that we have larger
especially technology corporations and
there's other industries too like
biotechnology is a big one in San Diego
and Schiller in the Bay Area right so
just in finance in New York and stuff
right so there's these big industries
that could do better at potentially not
necessarily going from 10 million to 100
million to a billion and just like
giving the shareholder extraction right
and they can also focus on rewriting
their own and maybe some of these
spiritual practices could help some of
these meditations and psychedelics and
these experiments when they look at
other people's eyes for like minutes at
a time so they can see and feel the
humanity in them and then they can
figure out maybe we should recycle some
of the things that that that could help
uplift other people yeah I mean you know
we're talking big issues here I mean a
big part of issues capitalism the way
it's set up you know we're talking you
know I'm a member of the battery I don't
know we look the better I'm an artisan
residence there and I don't pay for my
membership I know your artisan residence
fancy fancy fancy play there's only two
holes in this jacket supposed to be here
so I always say that like it's big
batteries the only place I feel
comfortable leaving my computer
unattended because interesting which
people don't steal from individuals they
steal from communities
you know it's like this [ __ ] guy Paul
Manafort got wet like like like 20
months in jail the same same day some
young black kid got never had any
offensive before got like five years or
eight years for stealing a pair of
Jordans yeah you know but who did he
hurt and who did Paul Manafort hurt you
know yeah so damn that's that's a that's
a really good example about the it's one
example that one of many examples coming
to the surface now you know yeah who we
are damn in these positions these people
of power garbage in garbage out you got
to be careful when you want to be
governed and led mmm just saying well
especially when we let the corporations
and the and the planers decide who it is
that's doing the leading and doing the
governing because therefore it's no
longer for the people it's for the
corporations well that's who we are
though I want to pose this question on
the both of you what would you do if you
had unlimited resources about okay
no let's I mean let's be care but
unlimited resources to do whatever I do
a lot of good news oh right Bezos has
unlimited resources but they want them
they want to go to Mars these guys want
to go to space this [ __ ] should be the
first one up against the wall I'm
telling you okay
let's [ __ ] kill them all I mean it's
just like Jeff Bezos to discuss
something that he said he's like I feel
things around the world that my money
can't fix so I want to go to Mars
instead or whatever it's like yeah
exactly
you're the richest person that's ever
lived your money can fix a lot of things
interesting like okay let me let me see
about that that question right like
practically first of all okay it's quite
nice that there is a quite an ease of
access you know some people even argue
that that like this whole you know click
and have it shipped to you in you know
two days or even less soon
is is even that beneficial like some
people even argue that that it's like no
it wouldn't it be better if you got off
your ass it went a couple blocks down
the street to a local business looked at
someone in the eyes engaged with the
bought from that those days are coming
to an end
but but even even like unlike a more
basic level than that how about paying
your workers well
letting them unionize how about not
using loopholes so that way you don't
pay your [ __ ] taxes these are just
basically this is just being like a like
literally a citizen this is being a
decent citizen pay your [ __ ] taxes
right yeah yeah
there's there's something very weird
about the culture of like them you know
like wealthy people high-fiving each
other based on how much they evaded
their taxes and there's think they get
Pat's in the back for doing things like
philanthropy right it's really great
that you put your name on a hospital you
gave a lot of money to it but how about
pay your taxes so that way that money
can be spent properly and not just what
you decide you shouldn't get pat on the
back for because of the money you give
through the philanthropy isn't nearly
what you should be keep paying anyways
to the state that they help take care of
everybody is a pet project yeah no no
art and all question then steward and
let me let me see it let me see if I can
table that question in my mind for a
moment while I just think about
answering what Ron posed which is you
know if you did have this extra wealth
what could be like an immediate thing to
address it does seem like a majority of
what I you know realize that is is
starting to you know change the way that
people see the world is is media and
mimetics so if you can really if like if
some of the things that maybe you could
do with that is is is distribute really
high quality short media maybe only 30
or 60 second clips maybe 20 minute film
short films but things that get people
to increase their awareness about how we
all evolved here on this rock how we
need to behave more
as a unity here on this rock how we can
apply a base line for everyone I think
that that's a very valuable investment
so anyway that would be maybe be one of
those things and then also like you
listed you know we give people the
humanity that they deserve the dignity
that they deserve that are the employees
of the organization that are the
communities that you're working with and
helping them come up ok question would
be you know a lot of people also tend to
tend to say that you know can we
actually wrap our minds around which
option is empirically proven to be
better when you tax individuals and
corporations and then distribute that
money through government programs and
try and see you know if you can make
education transportation infrastructure
those things usually you know work well
other things like there's been some
critique about you know welfare systems
there's know some critique about that
some critique about how well a private
corporation could potentially build out
a bridge versus a public entity right so
the argument sometimes is that private
sector putting money into building out
the advances that society needs could
potentially be better so taking their
tax well let's see how that worked with
healthcare that's a private sector and
then doing well that all let's look at
the prisons that's a private sector you
shouldn't put prices you shouldn't turn
people into commodities right yeah that
that's the difference if you like oh
so-and-so might be a good leader of the
country because they're a good business
person this isn't a business you're not
running a business you're running a
country got to think about keeping sick
people healthy you have to think about
educating people who don't have the
access to education that everybody else
has and you can't quantify that in ways
that a corporation will take care
because suddenly who the shareholders
it's never to be too poor people it's
never gonna be too sick people you know
it's never made like the queer people of
the people of color chose me the people
the top and so you can't you have to
like I mean we there's ways to make the
the state better and more transparent
and less bureaucracy but you have to you
if we don't believe in our state what is
there if we can't trust our state to to
take care of us and we can't believe
that it will take care of us and work
towards that
what is there we just [ __ ] become all
Ayn Rand mother
[ __ ] you know how do you feel about
artificial intelligence over governance
I mean legging through the robots that
we're looking long way to go well
artificial artificial intelligence not
necessarily the robot but you know just
maybe what the question rounds posing is
something along lines of like we're like
as you know you saw 2004 to 2019 and you
saw what happened in that 15 year period
we're about to get to you know 20 34
right that's the next 15 years umph that
we're gonna see and there's gonna be
some insane advances in artificial
intelligence and robotics that change
our society yeah how do you see that
well we're gonna we have a major problem
on the horizon and that's the job
pocalypse it's on that's coming at us
you have I mean took our jobs
took your jobs they're trying to take
all of our jobs man I mean just right
now for example there's there's hood
line is wasting they've raised ten
million dollars to put journalists out
of work forever they're trying to use AI
- right they're using a I'd to write
articles now I mean they're basically
mad libs they're mad libs that are
filling in the blanks yeah so like
justjust with taking truckers and people
do Drive uber and lyft integration
that's five million jobs right there
right and that's guaranteed in the next
ten years what those are gone right and
that's across the world that's even more
yeah right and like for example the
people who are doing Oberon left right
now but my parents drive for uber and if
they're older and my mom is like in her
like she's like 65 woman she's
expendable woman no one's gonna hire her
for a job it sucks
so she can do uber and lyft because it's
a job that she can actually doesn't have
to worry about the hiring and whatever
you know so what happens to the people
that are already on the fringes of
employment when those friends and play
jobs don't exist right the future needs
to be something like a university basic
income there needs to be you be I to
take care of the I mean I think there
was a shoe shoe rush coughs argument
around universal basic assets I don't
have no rush Chavez Douglas rushkoff
team human we love him had him on the
show he's a very very good argument for
you
basic assets which is low so it'd be
like you would gain a percentage of
ownership kind of like a co-op rather
than just an income right of ownership
of what of potentially some of the of
what you know you live in a in a in a
community and you're not getting any of
the asset ownership even though you're
constantly contributing to the community
success why'd you drop Roscoe's name
when I was the first one that told you
about what you know I just want to say
that I told you about that ubi wasn't
the way to go it was more about
universal basic shelter universal basic
meal allowance period and then you can
negotiate your value out in the private
sector when you're ready you got the
money the dollars that that whole
systems changing well as always there's
something that's taking into taking care
of people yeah few money but then
they'll raise the rates so my favorite
thing so what would the universal basic
assets in San Francisco be do we all get
a piece of Twitter so this is a good
question that that would it would be
much would be much better for someone
like Douglas rushkoff to address and
plus the the funny the funny thing about
this is that they're just all tiny
little pieces there there's no grand
proposal yet and right and we need a
grand proposal for what's coming well
the issue is that we're fundamentally
unprepared for when we have a monster in
the White House using white supremacists
or rather an orange supremacist who like
is [ __ ] there's no way the
Republicans are gonna let didn't even
let a medicare-for-all get it gonna
happen let alone something like ubi or
you be a right but that's a major
problem there's a study that from Oxford
that said in the next twenty five years
forty eight percent of the current jobs
are gonna disappear yeah right yeah so
there's Steve you in this room you know
what a half I wasn't gonna have jobs you
know and like the problem with that is
major because what do you do
what are you our government's not set up
for that yeah what do you do are so
civilization is not so the thing there
are several organizations that have now
said that within the next like around 25
years by like 2040 ish that almost 50%
of all jobs will be obsolete but a lot
of people counter
argue and say that there are gonna be
yeah I mean but someone has to connect
go somewhere after the robots for sure
the robot malfunction someone has to
clean up well but not just that also
things like there are tons of other
positions that open up regarding new
jobs that have yet to be conceived of
right those are very exciting things and
not on that scale there's no way yeah I
don't necessarily know about that skill
either but another thing that's
interesting is like some people argue
that there will be lots more of like
massage positions people will want to
get because robots and dexterity is
gonna take a really long time so you can
actually potentially open it more you
know you think you think it'll take a
while for robots to give you a better
massage we already have them at the
airport you sit down you hear that
sharper image you hear that yeah there's
nothing quite like you know getting the
actual you know rubbing from what else
the scale of new job creation and also
good jobs that's another thing like
their here's thing you have a [ __ ]
the [ __ ] twit ler from the White
House like to me like oh he's so proud
of his job numbers these aren't good
jobs being created you know like the
amount of people like right driving for
uber and lyft they're sure there's more
of those never before but those are good
jobs
there's no benefits there's no health
care you know there's no retirement
these are good jobs and there's no
ownership like co-op right and there's
no guaranteed money you know so like
sure there's like what are the quality
of jobs being created as a question does
not be an answered because just like you
know a [ __ ] graph that shows it's
like a line that's like this that
doesn't that's not deep that doesn't
tell you like how do I pay my bills with
this shitty job you know one of one of
the things that I think's very
interesting to take into account is this
population of like 330 million people
versus a population of just like 5
million people right you look at some
Scandinavian countries and you see like
hmm with like a lot less people it seems
to be quite easy to potentially have
rates of happiness and flourishing and
community that are just like really
strong for everyone well when these
people
their job we can all put them in a meat
grinder and just do the great calling
you know just remember thank you so much
sorry you have faith well I mean as to
what you're saying you know in Finland
there's this thing called startup
refugees and they uh they did this thing
where you know all these you have people
come from Syria and visit that into
Finland which has a strong social safety
net right and they say when the more
people that come in there
the more buoys down there social safety
net and what does that mean for our
society so what they did there's a thing
I'll start up refugees is really smart
they say how about we help these people
create their own jobs yeah so if you
come on you're a wood worker they're
gonna help you sell your wood shop that
way you can you're there you're employed
and then you can employ other refugees
so it's actively instead of being like
all right you're here figured out bro
it's like hey let's work together to
build something together and that way
you can in that way you can help people
get jobs they can help people get jobs
and suddenly they say social safety net
is once again being put into instead of
just taken out of the problem with this
country that the fundamental flaw in our
country is that it's a [ __ ] you get mine
mentality it's like hey buddy it's
nothing personal it's just business
it's his cowboy [ __ ] that's been in
part our thing from the very beginning
and I remember when I was in Japan right
and the first time I was there I
remember see the people wearing the
little face masks and I was like I was
like oh that's you know they were afraid
of getting sick no no they don't want to
get you sick that's that's the thing
it's it's a it's a part of the social
contract there is to give enough [ __ ]
about people around you right here it'd
be like hey whatever
[ __ ] you I'm sick don't worry you are
too now it's not my [ __ ] you know and so
and so that's the the ethos of our
country is is predicated on this get get
by get yours at all costs and that's
what's gonna have to change we have to
change and and what's gonna happen is
we're going towards some dark [ __ ] right
now in this country it may not be
guillotines but who knows
yeah we're going to it some dark [ __ ]
and I really want to
comments on the Japan thing was super
fascinating that that they wear that so
other people know that they're sick yeah
they don't breathe on they don't breathe
on you correct that's very that's very
community-oriented and that's very um
it's a really interesting interesting
thing that happens there and then the
and then the other thing that you
mentioned was this you mentioned before
that what would you mention before that
I talk a lot I know you mentioned
another really interesting thing right
before that everything I say is
interesting are you kidding
what was it right before that you know
what kind of [ __ ] interviewer using
these notes
it was another it was another really
good point it's okay the cowboy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you get my mentality uh-huh yeah
yeah it was something yeah yeah
Scandinavia and yeah oh yeah this in
within the social Eastern oh the refugee
startup star movie star refugees yes so
you know what's really interesting about
startup refugee is that if you take your
time and slow down and look at the
people around you that are on the edge
of falling into you know a bad place
that if you can help really address
every single human that's at that point
and help create help them create their
own job right have a one-on-one
mentorship have these programs at home
that I think we would experience a lot
less of the social problems that we have
another question is how do you organize
that and make that happen
that's something that that was the other
point I'm glad that we got there because
that's it that's a great one so the
thing with Finland and Norway and Sweden
and Denmark is they have much smaller
populations but we there are a lot fewer
resources you know like there's the
north of Finland the north of Norway and
gross [ __ ] there you know there's we
have an entire Midwest we can go
everything you have the Central Valley
here we can grow anything year round
right so we may have more people we have
a lot more resources and if we also
spend unfathomable amount of money on
the military every year if we put that
money you took that money away and put
that into health care and education yeah
right the kids in Finland they learn
right now starting the kindergarten they
learn English Swedish Finnish and they
learn how to code mm-hmm signing a
kindergarten earning kindergarten first
grade right yeah
here first of all you have their
problems teaching evolution in some
parts of this country so I mean so the
big problem is is this really the only
first world nation where only developed
nation where religion isn't diminishing
religiosity isn't diminishing right and
it's getting more intense in certain
pockets
I think this backwards idea of I mean
the Odyssey the Christian Right is a big
problem
[ __ ] y'all they're big problems in our
country they're the ones that are doing
and perpetrating a lot of this [ __ ] that
are keeping people uneducated they're
fighting against not all of them just of
course not all of them just a joke -
Chris the Christians for the KKK and
stuff like that you know but like it's
still boy stirring it's still like
bolstering rather the idea of like the
white Christian male that's like the
basis of the KKK you go go go by
Christian Mayo that's nothing and then
don't run I'm a Jew there's plenty of
[ __ ] up Jews out there - so you're
Christians it's not all your fault
plenty of [ __ ] up Muslims [ __ ] up
Buddhists any zealot of any kind is a
problem right if you believe you know
personally I can't believe that there's
some spooky guy in the sky it's gonna
fix everything and and I think that with
your religion is doesn't advocate for
community if your religion doesn't
advocate for loving all people how are
they are it's a bad religion you know
whatever your version of that religion
is and I think if your religion is
holding back science and holding back
you know ecology it's a bad religion I
don't care what the religion is sorry
Jews who don't agree with me sorry
Christians don't agree with me well I
think that that's just the extremity on
all sides of religion all the religions
have the same element of ignorance just
as they do enlightened loving beings
sure but in this country who's getting
put on the bench who's getting look at
what the koch brothers do you know look
at I mean those are real Christians it's
just they're been infiltrate
and stability galas ideologies of these
Christians that are being put into
practice dissipating behind Christianity
right like the Zionists hide behind Jews
sure that's a very controversial subject
but yeah you know I don't blame the Jews
for Zionism well then is an interesting
think is like it said it's obviously
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and complicated and
thing is I think that I mean I think
from the the thing with that word is
people have multiple definitions of it I
think growing up George I didn't think
of it as a bad word until recently when
I realized what it meant specifically
you know but at its base number that
were so many love different definitions
of it the idea of tiny ism being like
Israel has to expand and take over the
property you know all of them Palestine
that's [ __ ] up and I think the
settlements are [ __ ] up but like the
idea that Israel exists and I was right
to exist what does what country doesn't
have a right to exist okay that's enough
yeah talk any more about this we're
gonna get in trouble well shut us down
don't kill me they'll make it look like
I drug overdose or a suicide hmm so
that's enough let's move on I get scared
a couple couple thoughts you know you're
doing an independent media oh yeah right
we have all of Stuart's links below in
the bio who's patreon Twitter Instagram
Facebook etc the importance of
independent media needs to be very
seriously understood right now sure and
because there's a tremendous amount of
push for news conglomeration lobbyists
money fake news so an independent media
outlet one that doesn't have these
external influences causing it to be
biased is more important than ever I
know we speak on yeah well we're the
place where media is as important
especially good media like well research
stuff like your journalism is more as
important or more important than ever
but it's cultural value Rises while it's
financial and economic value decreases
what do you consider a valuable
source they have a new source yeah
somebody's just there's tons of them I
mean everything on a national level to a
local level you know I think like you
know Mission locals doing really great
work you know where they they're they're
reporting on the mission in a way that's
very local and very boots on the ground
that's important to that local district
of San Francisco you refer to sure but
also you know I think you know the Wall
Street Journal and the New York Post or
the New York Times they're also doing
some great work as well and or the
Russian imposed whatever there's there's
there's people that are doing actual
journalism and like the the mechanisms
in the system that it's set up is broken
the business of media has broken the
business of journalism is broken and
attention economic side of things with
advertisements well even this is the way
that advertisement should have set up is
all [ __ ] up because I can't Isis the
click baby
and right there really quick new cycle
stuff and well you have this thing where
they all of a sudden news is not only 24
hours but now it's every second of the
day right and so you have so that's it
everything you that's little e you have
to compete when there was three TV
channels right and you had three
newspapers news in your city there was
only so many sources you could get
information from right but when you have
an infinite possibility of news these
things have to like make crazier
headlines and crazier images just to get
your attention but the thing is like for
example on my website if an article gets
1500 views to make a dollar like one
dollar next 1500 views yeah that's
unsustainable
yeah it's unsustainable yeah so how do
you fix that
I think hood line should have should
raise that 10 million dollars to help
fix that problem instead of help build
robots to write news you know I think
that we need to invest in our and the
Fourth Estate you know that was the
Third Estate was a like fourth
Industrial Revolution good the fourth
revolution technology well they called
the Fourth Estate or the Third Estate
whatever was with the journalism I know
I got no estate so doesn't matter yeah
but it's super problematic yeah so so
the system that we've been done for all
these years is broken how do you fix
that
you need a new system right right now
we're seeing more things like patreon we
get like about a quarter of our income
every month from patreon and that's
super helpful because I know that like
you know Dobby months when I make we're
broke a Stewart and I say I say
procaster I don't need me I mean it's a
whole organization because I got like
you know lots of people who who do
different things that I pay different
you know and so it cause like $4,500 a
month run that yeah exactly
and we bring about $1,500 a month from a
patreon yeah
so there's some ones where I only make
1,500 ollars there's other bunch we make
you know $10,000 and how you know how do
you do that consistently exactly so
independent media is really important
because how can you you know can't be
bought if nobody's buying you know yeah
I'm kind of rambling at this point that
this very these are very important
points though 47 - I forgot you I yeah
yeah I flipped oh that's perfect I
flipped over the timer Ronnie yes so
this is broadcaster akami I should check
it out the links in the bio and yeah
this is unsustainable the 1500 views for
$1 patreon is helping out a bit this is
a good source patreon there's other
sorts of ways to do this that have yet
to be discovered like we talked about
Lorenzo de Medici on our show the patron
of the Arts insurance that gave
Michelangelo and avenging their ability
to flourish right so there's so many of
these interesting ways to cycle
potentially wealth into artists and
entrepreneurs and give them the
stability to creatively flourish and I
think that that it's about time - for
people to understand that these
independent people having voices to be
able to communicate things is super
important for for the for potentially
even for truth
- to make its way into a more and more
of the culture away from the noise
there's so much noise as well with
everyone having a voice and talking
about what
they think it's important at the time
and it's making it difficult for
sometimes for science to take a
precedence and and to push forth with
that okay couple other thoughts this was
interesting in 2015 you ran for mayor of
San Fran
okay so yeah tell us about this this is
because I'm shy and not opinionated I
ran for mayor I had no intentions of
winning I wasn't going to win so that
was an issue but it was an it was an
opportunity to to to kick up dirt just
stir [ __ ] up to get people to pay
attention to things that maybe not would
have maybe wouldn't been paid attention
before that you know and we did I did a
great job of that and I teamed up
there's two other people running for
mayor we teamed up Amy Farrah Weiss and
Francisco Herrera we did this thing
because we have ranked what likes that
ticket by the way I just want to say
that you were fantastic great idea that
was Emmy wife's idea and it was a great
idea Amy's been almost sure we need to
get Francisco on the show yeah she was
great yep great dude so yeah when
collectively we got like over 40% of the
vote you know which is huge yeah for
three like Dark Horse candidates yeah
and damn you know it as a guy who's the
pro cast to it who shouldn't be mayor I
got like 10% of the vote which is
[ __ ] rad because there's an
opportunity to like get to stick up for
my city and call out people need to be
called out surely you should be mayor
why not I don't want to be mayor that's
the only way I could have lost that
election is if I had won that election
that's one of the things that I'm
excited for democracy 2.0 or the next
sort of of what we usher in as the next
nobody want nobody that has their ego
has had their ego quelled wants to take
a position of leadership in terms of
like leading other people they just want
to build out the the infrastructure that
enables everyone to collectively
contribute to what we're building here
on planet earth not like some top-down
mayoral or presidential
that that's that's what I'm seeing more
and more of is oh yeah it's like I don't
anybody who wants to be president I
don't trust to be president you know who
the hell wants to be you as that [ __ ]
job you gotta be at Eagle maniac you
know but I also like I don't want I
don't want to deal with the bureaucracy
either like it just I just want to do
cool [ __ ] and like create [ __ ] and make
cool things and yeah and and then stir
up [ __ ] up from the sidelines sidelines
I don't want to yeah yeah
be an actual politician sounds terrible
there's a much better way to get
everyone contributing without the need
for like a top-down sort of pressure and
I think the founding fathers of this
country as well as the the the people
around the world are starting to realize
that it's time to update some of the
code to be inclusive in terms of
building the systems that we want to see
it not a top-down way of seeing them Ron
can you throw up our our simulation
again it's okay couple quick questions
on the way out yes okay first question
this is simulation so we must ask you
are we in a simulation
maybe anything's possible men I mean or
what if we're just like you know if on a
cellular level of substrate level you
there's like you know a nucleus and
electrons and protons and what powers
electrons and protons you know maybe
this conversation is part our in some
part of electron it's in a tiny tiny bit
of part of his skin in some giant you
know who'd a few [ __ ] knows I had
this kind of great stone thought the
other day that uh what we see at achill
physicists are correct and there's an
infinite amount of worlds and universes
what if every time we go to sleep we
really your dreams just us like kind of
like touching base with our other selves
and that's right being so [ __ ] weird
we love that thought that one such a
good one
now it's so good uh I feel like we also
do some of that a little bit during the
day like at night when you go and dream
into it you it feels like you're
definitely going into the parallel
universes and experiencing what's
happening there sometimes it definitely
feels like that but even during the day
you can get little you know close your
eyes a little bit you know you can tap
into maybe like what would it be like if
you did this action instead of that
action right and then you can kind of
like simulate what would have happened
that kind of stuff I don't know I know
that I'm not smart enough to know again
one of the most important things is to
say that you know we know nothing that
maybe we'd be humble AF yeah that's
super important alright last question
yeah what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world
my girlfriend love love like that
feeling of like just loving somebody and
living other people and like letting
that grow and create beauty and create
good you know and looking out for people
because of love you know I'm growing it
within love no look at the camera and
tell her how much you love her down but
yeah like you know it sounds cheesy but
like really love love is so dope
it really is help you find the good
things in yourself you know I love
Chinese food that's a beautiful thing in
the world is your girlfriend I'm sure
she'll appreciate I like I love Szechuan
when you get your mouth all nama that's
my kind of love yeah yeah the that's we
we hear love a lot on the show and I and
I I think a lot of people like to kind
of do a little like escape from the
craziness of civilization into love sure
like they can just cuddle with their
partner and just enjoy something
together sure and that that can be such
a profound sense of connection yeah yeah
Stewart what a [ __ ] pleasure man let
me rant this really really fun and so
many topics covered
I appreciate that it'll be interesting
to see how much they hate me in the
comment section oh my gosh seriously the
the amount of working you know you've
seen it in the last 15 years and undone
and an experience and I hope people can
also you know check out how to be you
know young broke and beautiful and
really embody that and also you know see
some of the you know these travel guide
tips for people and furthermore like
have these conversations around you
everyone have these tough conversations
what is the best way to structure our
society moving forward we've had some
great conversation on this episode about
that I'm really happy we dived into that
thanks everyone for tuning and we
greatly greatly appreciate it we would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below with your thoughts have
yeah we'd love to
we'd love to keep building the future
with everyone here huge shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing we
love you very much thank you thank you
guys support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in right
you know you have Stewart here you have
simulation here right all our links are
below Stewart's links are below like get
supporting of the people that you
believe and let's catalyze the next
entrepreneurs and artists to be more
successful go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much huge thank
you for tuning in you are young broken
beautiful we love you so much we'll see
you soon everyone peace
[Applause]
you
[Music]